might it be
just going to flow to theory here
that these
affluent owners
in napa the same ones who blocked
native son george lucas
from building
uh you know museums for the community
and who blocked george lucas from
building a studio up in the area up
there north of the golden gate bridge
these maniacs
are so rich and entitled that maybe
the idea that somebody who could only
afford one-eighth of a napa home
would be showing up for their vacation
in napa might that have something to do
with it you think
again i i can't speak for i can't speak
for what's driving or motivating um
you know the the people who who don't
really like our concept but what i what
i can tell you again back to the facts
what i can tell you is our average home
price is four million dollars so when we
when we first started hearing the
feedback from the community i mean the
number one thing that we heard was that
we were taking homes away from the local
workforce affordable homes away from the
local workforce it's so disingenuous
and and we and to and we did buy one
house for 1.2 million which was twice
the median in the in the neighborhood
that we bought in we acknowledged we
heard from the community acknowledged
that that that probably wasn't the right
property for our model and we chose to
sell the house you know outright and a
second homeowner i i think actually
ended up buying it but all of our homes
now like our average home price is four
million dollars so these are not
affordable homes that's for sure yeah
you know these are homes that would have
otherwise been purchased by second
homeowners if you just look at the
numbers and the percent of people who
are purchasing these multi-million
dollar homes they're second homeowners
and so we think it's a much better use
of housing stock to consolidate demand
into fewer homes but the other thing
that we think is really powerful is the
the sort of the transfer of the demand
that's happening through this model all
the people who are coming into into the
picasso model like these are these are
not families who just woke up like last
week and decided that they wanted to own
a second home these are families who had
been dreaming about owning a second home
for a long time many years in most cases
and most of them are actively in the
market working with a real estate agent
or shopping on redfin or zillow for for
a home already and if it weren't for
picasso many of these second homeowners
would be buying median priced homes they
would buy the 600k one million dollar
home and take it away from a school
teacher a firefighter
an accountant somebody who you know is
getting priced out of these markets i
think that these nimby people have the
worst intent in the world i think that
they bought their houses early they've
seen them appreciate in value and they
delight in there being limited inventory
and they delight in there being no other
option because it makes their most prime
asset their home their second home that
they got in early appreciate in value
and they are so
so anti-community
that they
don't want certain demographics to be
next door to them i think that's what a
lot of this is about i'll be totally
honest and i think they want to protect
their investment which is reasonable
except these are homes and people need a
place to live and people need a place to
have their second homes they got
particularly vicious with you in in napa
maybe you could talk a little bit about
some of the uh and i know your media
people and pr people don't want you to
talk about this but they were pretty
they got a little edgy with you up there
tell us what did they do to try to stop
you they made it pretty personal
yeah why look i i should clarify that
it's not everybody like we have we have
i mean we're in 25 destinations now
across the us and and you know a lot of
a lot of people are are really welcoming
their new neighbors with open arms like
i was just in aspen last week uh for the
the food and wine festival where where
we we had some activities going on for
picasso and i actually got to meet one
of our neighbors she came out of her way
she basically came over to our property
introduced herself and she opened up by
saying
thank you so much these homes
surrounding me i've been living here in
aspen for 30 years and all these homes
on my street sit empty for 10 months per
year i'm so thankful to have neighbors
and friends and members of the community
that that previously weren't here so
it's not everybody but you're right that
in you know some some neighbors aren't
quite as welcoming um and they basically
put up like signs and cars
and like
banners that picasso was destroying napa
and sonoma yeah i mean you know we've
had threats threats to burn down our
houses we've had yeah that was the crazy
thing in the npr story yeah that was
like because once i found out about you
i googled you
because i was gonna invite you on the
show and i dm'd you on um twitter i
think and then i saw the npr story and i
was like oh my god they threatened to
burn the house down this is how deranged
these sociopaths are these nimby socials
we've had threats that we should be shot
literal physical violence i mean
not only property violence but shooting
you this is deranged and you know what
it is because i you won't say it i will
they think that people who are not white
people are going to come to napa and
underneath of a home who couldn't
previously afford it that's what this is
about i'm sorry and they're just also
concerned that maybe if you're a more
affordable solution when they want to
flip their house they won't have a buyer
because somebody says oh this is more
efficient but they should be thinking
these nimby sociopaths what they should
be thinking is what kind of society do i
want to live in one where people can't
afford homes and people have to suffer
and and have to live an hour and a half
away and and we all this inventory dries
up we need a solution picasso is a great
solution
take the win napa
other places we think
yeah i was gonna say we we definitely
think it's a great solution i mean it'll
it'll take time for people to understand
any new concept as you mentioned in the
opening jason like anything i've ever
been a part of or seen that was doing
something new and industry and
interesting faces some resistance and it
takes time for people to fully
understand and appreciate the concept
and yeah i think co-ownership is one of
those things that'll just take some time
and you know we're we're going out of
our way to try to to to try to
communicate as well like you know we
want to be part of the solution not part
of the problem here like as an example
you know and and one of our properties
this weekend we we hosted a pancake
breakfast you know
to get to know our our owners our chief
revenue officer stayed at the home he
hand cooked every single pancake by
himself he handed out flyers
to every neighbor on the street as well
as the neighbors on the adjoining street
and just invited them over from nine to
11 a.m just to have a conversation and
get to know us and guess how many people
showed up
you tell me
zero uh
zero
so well you know we're trying to have
the conversations uh we want to be part
of the solution but we also realize that
that it'll take time for this this
concept to be understood
listen right now linkedin is going to
give you a hundred dollar credit towards
your first ad campaign i want you to go
to linkedin.com
this week in startups and get that
hyundy right now now why would you use
linkedin marketing
high quality leads we all need leads
we're all running businesses here my
leads startup founders your leads might
be sas enterprise it might be cfos it
might be cmos it might be ctos who knows
everybody's got a different product but
everybody is on linkedin we all know
that because we all use linkedin every
single day so if you're planning a
launch a new campaign you know your
audience your team is excited and
everything is going according to plan
we've all been there except you have
that one thought in the back your head
how can i be sure that my acquisition
campaign will drive high impact leads
for my sales team well with linkedin ads
you don't need to guess because when you
advertise on linkedin your message
reaches people who are ready to engage
you linkedin equals business business
equals linkedin you know this it's very
simple so with 30 million companies
engaging and over 71 of professionals
using linkedin to inform their business
decisions
linkedin can help bring your growth to
the next level
don't wait to start achieving your brand
and lead gen goals get a 100 ad credit
towards your first linkedin campaign at
linkedin.com
this week in startups once again
linkedin.com slash this week in startups
for the hyundy no spaces no dashes and
terms and conditions apply because
they're giving you a handy